[Music]
so in the early days including from the
time of Aristotle and later in 16 and
17th century most of physiognomy
consisted of this whimsical comparisons
between the physiognomy of humans and
animals so for example you would have a
drawing of a human who presumably look
looks like a cow and from there you will
make all kinds of inferences that
perhaps the character of the person
matches the character of the cow
whatever that might be in fact if you
look at the history of European history
most of the 19th century's novels a
standard feature of this analysis that
you have his genomic descriptions of the
characters so it was a big very very
popular in it in influence not only
marginal writers but big names like
Balzac Stendhal and many others now
interestingly enough in the early 20th
century people no longer talk about
physiognomy they talk about character
analysis and in fact a lot of the
references no longer tool avatars
whimsical ideas but they're to
evolutionary ideas and the so called
character angle is they were quite
influential and they were involved
heavily in business and recruitment of
employees but this is exactly the time
when the new science of psychology
arises and then psychologists are kind
of skeptical about the claims of the
character analyst or really the new
fujian amidst the fact that we agree and
this impression was discovered over
hundred years ago in psychology but
psychologists at the time were really
focused on the accuracy of the
impressions and paid very little
attention to the extremely interesting
psychological fact that we actually
agree on these impressions very often in
psychology and in many and generally in
the social sciences lately if you
observe that there's a pervasive bias
that is it's something that feels
failure automatic and we can all do it
there is a kind of almost an immediate
assumption that my this might be
actually wired that it's
something that we are born to be able to
do of course you can easily think of
counter examples like learn driving
which essentially becomes automatic and
there's nothing evolutionary about
driving or reading but nevertheless
thinks that seems to have been present
always in our environment like faces
that seems like a natural assumptions
it's interesting actually we've done
some studies it's as I said there are
many many different inputs to
impressions right one is emotional
expressions there's stereotypes about
gender
there's cues about age in facial
maturity all of these go into our
impressions another one that is very
interesting is typicality so as it
turned out we tend to like phases that
are typical that means phases that the
closer to what we perceive is typical in
our social environment now though
there's an interesting wrinkle because
typicality is also culturally specific
especially if if the different cultures
are linked to different ethnicities and
there is distinctive physiognomy x' and
that makes it worse we've done a study
where we created morphs of a typical
Japanese face and a typical Israeli face
and then we can Interpol interpolate the
morph so we can imagine like a typical
Japanese face gradually turning in a
typical Israeli face now if you ask
Israeli in Japanese participants to
evaluate the faces what happens is that
as the face become more Israeli looking
the Israelis believe that the face is
becoming more trustworthy and the other
way around for the Japanese so in a
sense to a large extent what we perceive
is typically shaped by our natural
environment and it's something that we
very rapidly extract we learn incredibly
good learners about faces and and most
likely people who live in New York City
which the hugely diverse face will have
a different notion of typicality if you
live in a small rural
where there's not so much diversity and
in this case it's another so in this
case this can lead to different kind of
soap operas optimal outcomes because
naturally we wouldn't trust people that
do not look like us not having any other
information the reason why we will never
be able to get rid of first impressions
is because they serve important
psychological functions that is in the
absence of any other information we are
trying the best we could
to figure out what the other people are
thinking that doesn't mean that that we
wouldn't change our minds on the
contrary when you have a good diagnostic
evidence about the person or when you
know about past behavior that would
change your inferences based on
appearance but most of the time if you
don't have any other information people
will act on this and that may not be in
their best interest
starting back with that azaireyah
Lombroso who wrote books like the
criminal man and the criminal woman and
he claimed that he can identify these
inferior types based on their facial
features to Francis Galton who invented
the composite photography and in fact
all of the today's morphing methods are
based on this method of composite
photography and the first application of
the method was to identify the criminal
type so it has a very long history I
think that a very reasonable argument
could be that we are kind of hardwired
to figure out the intentions of other
people of the people around us because
what is the most important thing in our
social life it's other people and in
interactions with strangers you're
always trying to figure out what are the
intentions are they good are they bad
what are they going to do can they hurt
me whether that's physical or in a
non-physical way so these are things
that have always been a concern for us
now but let's think in terms of
evolutionary history well for most of
our evolutionary history basically
lifting extended families typically
between five to eighteen DVD
all of these changes in the last 50,000
in fact even less maybe in the last
20,000 years when you have large
societies there is if you imagine the
human evolution compressed within 24
hours we have been living with strangers
surrounded by strangers in the last 5
minutes so it is not obvious at all that
we are kind of in doubt of reading the
characters of other front faces I think
there's very good evidence to be there's
good comparative evidence that in fact
we are very good at picking up on social
cues in the immediate situations so if
you look for example in comparative
studies you look at across all primates
turns out that we had the only primate
which has whites of the eyes that is our
iris is dark then you have the white
sclera and then have a darker skin there
are no other primates with these kinds
of coloration so why is that kind
interesting or important well the fact
that you have the white of the sclera
makes it super easy to detect eye gaze
an eye gaze is very important for
sharing social attention we can
communicate from a long distance similar
emotional expressions are very important
the fact that we have kind of that one
the naked ape and the fact that our
faces are not completely covered by hair
makes very detection to makes it very
easy to detect changes in skin
coloration switch often indication of
them are different kinds of emotional or
mental states so we are very sensitive
to changes momentary changes in what we
are observing because this momentary
changes indicative of what is important
in the situation what is happening right
now but it is hard to make the argument
that somehow we end out also to read
into the faces the character of others I
think we have the natural propensity to
trying to figure out what this other
people are thinking or feeling right now
but that doesn't mean and I think the
problem with physiognomy and and the
modern version is this assumption that
because you can make this rapid
inferences they're also informative
about these people across time and
situations
[Music]